[Musique]
et
si louis napoléon bonaparte n'avait pas
été sensible aux charmes de hyde park
durant son séjour à londres les
parisiens n'auraient pas eu de bois de
boulogne
du moins celui qu'ils connaissent
aujourd'hui car c'est un napoléon iii
qu'on doit l'aménagement du massif
il était entouré de murailles jusqu'à la
veille de la révolution c'est seulement
sous le second empire que les grandes
allées ont été percés que les deux lacs
et les rivières ont été creusés et les
grands hippodromes réalise au bois de
boulogne on vient se détendre pour
s'oxygéner pour oublier la ville et ça
colle pour retrouver la quiétude le
silence
en principe
[Musique]
m
voici ce qu'est devenu le bois un
immense autodrome il est pratiquement
impossible aujourd'hui dans un massif de
850 hectares de trouver un endroit où on
ne voit et on entend pas les voitures
[Musique]
on veut se demander ce que font ces
voitures dans le bois alors que ce n'est
véritablement pas leur place ce n'est
pas leur place et certains se demandent
ils y a des voix qui finalement sont des
voies de transit qui rend presque la
même fonction que des routes nationales
où près jamais parce que dire des
autoroutes
vous avez des voiles du bois de boulogne
dans lesquels vous avez des circulations
de 4000 véhicules heure comme nationale
d'enfants par exemple au drame
mais oui et ceux ci et 4000 véhicules
heure c'est la circulation de
l'autoroute à une heure de pointe
bientôt vous allez avoir entre la porte
d'auteuil et le pont de sèvres une
autoroute qui va rejoindre le boulevard
périphérique à l'autoroute de l'ouest
alors rien j'espère que cette autoroute
ou permettra précisément délimité très
considérablement la circulation dans le
voit c'est une promesse
c'est un voeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais les voitures ne sont pas que sur
les grands axes
malheureusement nos concitoyens n'aime
pas beaucoup marcher à pied et ils
veulent bien faire une première de bois
de boulogne à utiliser les agréments
décevoir et des établissements du pop du
lot mais ils veulent d'abord s'y rendre
en voiture et c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous me voyez pas de voitures
qui stationnent dans les allées du bois
et c'est effectivement un phénomène
regrettable
il faudrait réapprendre à nos
concitoyens à marcher à pied un
politique vers laquelle on s'oriente
actuellement temps plus tôt a interdit à
la circulation dans les boîtes et à
obliger les automobilistes à abandonner
leur voiture avant l'entrée du bois
plutôt qu'à créer des aires de
stationnement dans le bois même une
autre politique consiste plutôt à faire
utilisé par les automobilistes les
possibilités de stationnement qui sont
situés aux abords du bois exemple
parking foch parking de la porte
d'auteuil
vous avez beaucoup de gardiens de la
paix qui s'occupe de réglementer la
vitesse et la circulation n'a pas de
boulot je ne parvenais à chiffres exacts
nous avons des courses par exemple on
shore une manifestation importante au
parc des princes des effectifs n'ont
rien de comparable avec ce qu'ils sont
là dimanche creux de la saison d'automne
ou d'hiver le bois de boulogne et déjà
percé comme un gruyère
mais le plus grave a certainement été
causés par le passage du boulevard
périphérique
qui a supprimé des milliers d'ha alors
on peut se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi on a choisi un tracé qui
massacrent tout un secteur
[Musique]
le technicien ne peut donner que des
indications ne pas faire que des
propositions et des suggestions donné
les avantages des inconvénients de telle
ou telle solution est en définitive aux
politiques surtout dans un cas aussi
difficile à apprécier la solution qu'il
a lieu d'adopter alors tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que techniquement
il était effectivement possible
je ne dis pas souhaitable mais possible
de passer au droit de l'allée des
fortifications les services techniques
avaient étudié en fait trois séries de
solution celle que nous connaissons et
qui a été réalisée une solution le nom
de la désertification et des solutions
beaucoup plus tard l'ouest en banlieue
du bois de boulogne qui nécessitait
d'ailleurs des destructions
d'habitations en nombre assez
considérable
partout ailleurs les riverains ont été
gênés également par les travaux du
périphérique ils le sont encore on a un
peu l'impression on a cherché à moins
gêné ces riverains que d'autres et je me
permettrai de vous répondre que partout
ailleurs il n'avait peut-être pas
tellement de solutions et plat il y
avait un choix possible et ce choix pu
être exercé pour les autres routes
vous voyez notre solution un
périphérique autour du bois de boulogne
qu'il n'est sans doute pas question
peut-être de financer à l'heure actuelle
mais qui verra peut-être jour le jour le
bois est bruyant illimité et de plus il
vieillit mal
il s'étiole des arbres sont en train de
mourir depuis bientôt cent cinquante ans
cette forêt est techniquement tréviers
alors que fait d'euros eh bien depuis
déjà depuis déjà trente ans il a fallu
s'occuper de la régénération de cette
forêt et on ne pouvait pas procéder par
des méthodes de régénération naturelle
comme on le fait souvent dans les grands
domaines de l'état parce que la forêt
avaient été amenés à une époque trop
avancé et parce que il ne fallait pas
ôter à la disposition du public de trop
grands espaces
car c'est un espace que vous avez ôté au
public celui ci effectivement pour faire
une régénération de cet ensemble qui a
commencé je le répète il ya une
trentaine d'années il faut évidemment
choisir des clairières
comme celle ci qui était
particulièrement dégradée qui ont une
superficie de 1 hectare en hectares et
demi environ
et combien de temps faudra-t-il avant
que cette parcelle soit rendu au public
maintenant 23 ans environ alors ici en
fait nous sommes vingt ans après oui et
même un petit peu plus cet enclos a été
libéré il y a deux ans environ et des
séquoia et des bouleaux et celui ci va
être libéré l'année prochaine un très
beau massif avec des cèdres depuis 1930
date à laquelle a commencé ses
régénération 140 enclos ont été
successivement mis en production
à l'heure actuelle il y en a encore 80
qui sont enserrés entre leur grille ce
qui représente combien d'hectares déjà
rendu au péglé déjà rendu au public plus
de 40 hectares en dehors du reboisement
il y à d'autres problèmes les rhb aussi
devient rare on en trouve pratiquement
plus sur les pelouses pas partout il
faut savoir n'est ce pas que la forêt
est une ville en état d' équilibre avec
son seul toute amélioration de laon se
traduit par une amélioration de l'autre
et réciproquement
dans ce bois où il ya une fréquentation
importante
on a calculé qu'elle pouvait faire sept
mille personnes par hectare et par an
alors que par exemple en forêt de
rambouillet à 55 kilomètres de paris
elle est de 300 personnes seulement le
piétinement de la foule n'explique pas
tout il ya malheureusement beaucoup
d'autres causes à cette disparition il
ya également long qui est utilisé dans
les plantations et qui est utilisé aussi
pour l'alimentation des lacs et des
rivières du bois qui s'étendent tout de
même sur plus de 8 km
cette eau qui est de l'eau brute de
seine refoulé dans le réseau est
maintenant très pollué par les
détergents ou par des phosphates et quoi
d'autre encore eh bien naturellement
l'air et la circulation automobile
tous ces gars sont tout de même nocif
pour les végétaux surtout vers les
étages inférieurs
alors le remède on leur met le remède
c'est évidemment la ré un désengagement
tout au moins à l'égard de la
circulation automobile
des enclaves il y en a beaucoup on les
appelle des concessions elle monopolise
157 ha soit le cinquième du bois même si
l'on retire les 94 hectares des deux
hippodromes et les 17 hectares du jardin
d'acclimatation
il reste encore 46 ha partagé entre des
cafés des restaurants et des clubs
sportifs réservés à leurs adhérents
[Musique]
enfin il y a quelque chose de pitoyable
c'est la négligence des promeneurs
qu'est ce que c'est que ce tas de
ferraille et bien ceci est le résultat
de six mois de ramassage dans le bois de
boulogne
vous voyez tout ce qu'il peut y avoir
des vélomoteurs des réfrigérateurs une
voiture de la ferraille de toutes sortes
ce tas était absolument nu il y a cinq
six mois et aujourd'hui nous pas vous
voyez ce qui a été ramassé de cette
façon et dans six mois il y en aura
malheureusement autant
à moins que le public nous prenait tout
de même conscience de la nécessité où il
se trouverait de respecter un petit peu
davantage cette promenade
[Musique]
et
oh
un plan de rajeunissement et de
sauvegarde a été mis au point par la
préfecture de paris et les conseillers
de paris l'ont approuvé
tout le monde est d'accord pour
l'appliquer si on le fait sérieusement
avec beaucoup de foi et de bonne volonté
ce qui reste du bois de boulogne peut
être encore sauvée ce qui donnera
peut-être aux parisiens demain l'envi
d'aller plus loin et de reconquérir ce
qui leur a été enlevé
[Musique]